okay now i'm on on a pretty decent  streak so that's uh  that's a good start  john king do you think everybody plays  like this for some reason  i have no idea why can i take this this  is the weirdest line i've seen  a couple of hours  since i played yes it's your plan  okay i'm uh a little  my development is  a little bit [ __ ] if you're allowed  i think you're actually allowed to say  that  yeah maybe they'll ban you on twitch but  oh knight c6 was possible yeah i've got  knight d5 now  take on c3 possibly  still my development is a bit of an  issue but  it should be fine  yeah we'll just  give this one go king f8 and then  i'll escape  yeah kg7  so i'm completely winning knight two  pulse up and a better position to boot  take this rook c1 there's bishop d5  queen g4 just go back  and again  resignation would not be insane for my  opponent but  there we go  cringey firework edge one queen two four  wow okay